das ist vielleicht der durchbruch auf
der suche nach leben auf dem mars die
nasa hat strukturen fotografiert die
tatsächlich spuren von leben auf dem
mars bedeuten könnten
die hinterlassenschaften eines masters
und wenn man sie hier auf der erde
finden würde würde sie jeder genau als
das als tierischen ursprungs deuten also
was wann wo wie ist die lage auf dem
mars jetzt bei klick zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
ja wir haben ja schon öfter über leben
auf dem mars berichtet und die
möglichkeiten dass es tatsächlich
zumindest in der vergangenheit möglich
war immer wieder werden indizien
gefunden überall im all werden hinweise
darauf gefunden dass leben vielleicht
nicht die ausnahme sondern der
normalfall im weltall ist dann wäre der
mars einer der top-kandidaten für leben
und erst vor wenigen tagen hat der mars
reconnaissance orbiter
riesige mengen wasser entdeckt wir haben
hier ja darüber berichtet aber was der
mars rover curiosity am 15 dezember
fotografieren hat das ist wirklich
atemberaubend auf dieser aufnahme sind
oben auf einem stein spuren zu sehen wie
hier auf der erde ganz klar lebewesen
zugeordnet werden würden die
übermittlung der daten vom mars zur erde
dauert der etwas und auch die analyse
nach wenigen tagen fand das team der
choreo city diese spuren auf den fotos
und war elektrisiert sofort schickten
sie den rover zurück um die struktur
näher zu untersuchen noch untersuchen
sie die fundstelle vollkommen
ergebnisoffen doch jetzt ist schon klar
diese fundstelle ist so oder so
historisch das forschungsteam forscher
zunächst in richtung von geologischen
erklärung die wissenschaftliche
gründlichkeit erfordert dieses vorgehen
und bevor irgendjemand seine
wissenschaftliche karriere beschädigt
dadurch dass er spuren von leben meldet
ist man da besonders vorsichtig als
erstes berichtete der amerikanische
journalist lena david über die
entdeckung recherchierte weiter und
befragte wissenschaftler zu dieser
entdeckung einer war es schön war sawada
wissenschaftler vom mars science
laboratory so der chor city projekttitel
er sagte zulehner david über die
möglichkeit dass es sich um
versteinerungen handelt also spuren von
leben
wir schließen es nicht aus aber das wird
sicher nicht unsere erste interpretation
sein und wenn einiges darauf hin deutet
ist noch fraglich ob die instrumente des
mars rover curiosity überhaupt
ausreichen um das zu bestätigen also um
leben zu bestätigen die neuesten fotos
bestärken jedenfalls den eindruck des
tierischen ursprungs sie sind rund ein
bis zwei millimeter dick diese
strukturen und fünf millimeter lang wie
die versteinerung der hinterlassenschaft
eines warum sie auf der erde der
astrobiologe barry die
gregorio von der university of
buckingham diese strukturen gleichen
lebensspuren aus dem ordovizium die ich
selbst schon hier auf der erde
untersuchen und fotografieren konnte
noch sind das alles aber wirklich nur
spekulation aber spricht schon einiges
dafür zunächst sind solche spuren hier
auf der erde
in den allermeisten fällen tierischen
ursprungs sie deuten auf eine bi turbo
aktion durch lebewesen hin dass heißt
sedimente wie zum beispiel sand werden
durch würmer durchwühlt sie hinterlassen
dabei gänge füllen die sich wieder mit
anderem material das sich wieder
verfestigt wird der sand dann
weggeblasen
dann bleiben genau diese gebilde wie auf
dem mars übrig es können aber auch gänge
übrig bleiben je nachdem was nach dem
durchwühlen passiert ist die
ähnlichkeiten mit fossilien
versteinerung also hier auf der erde ist
jedenfalls frappierend und anders herum
fragt sich barry di gregorio welcher
geologische vorgang überhaupt solche
strukturen erzeugen könnte ja fraglich
es bleibt also dabei der eindruck dass
es micro fossilien tierischen ursprungs
sein könnten drängt sich auf andere
ideen gibt es noch gar nicht der mars
bleibt auf jeden fall so oder so eines
der spannendsten themen zurzeit ich
halte euch hier natürlich auf dem
laufenden
zur aktuellen entwicklung wenn er kein
video dazu und auch zu allen an dem
verpassen wollten dann wird mir hier ein
abos auge unvergesslich dem genau auf
die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch
immer über neue videos informieren
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken außerirdisches leben an
viel mehr orten möglich ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran